19 avril 1971 il ya tout juste 50 ans la
guerre froide se déroule dans l'espace
c'est le moment choisi par l'union
soviétique pour lancer la toute première
station spatiale sale [ __ ] avec soyouz
autres et salue les soviétiques pourront
passer du provisoire
dans le défilé
sayoud un élancée du cosmodrome de
baïkonour au kazakhstan
là même où youri gagarine est devenu le
premier homme à aller dans l'espace
dix ans plus tôt le 23 avril 1971 quatre
jours après la mise en orbite de saliou
tu trois cosmonautes d'école en
direction de la station à bord du vol
soyouz 10 mai l'opération démarrage est
un échec il faut attendre le 6 juin 1971
pour qu'une nouvelle mission soit lancée
soyouz 11 à bord trois cosmonautes
georges dreux vol ce qui vous le voyez
ici 43 ans commandant de bord et n'a
jamais volé ladislas volkov l'ingénieur
du vol a déjà volé en octobre 69 à bord
de soyouz 7 et victor pas de cf
l'ingénieur décès c'est aussi un bleu de
l'espace soyouz 11 est une réussite au
bout de 90 minutes de voyage
les trois hommes rejoignent s'ajoute un
sans encombre ici vous avez dobrowolski
le commandant colonel 43 ans commandant
de bord qui commentent littéralement le
lancement avant même la satellisation et
pendant toute l'expérience vous avez la
transmission télévisée c'est vraiment un
système très opérationnelle à plus de
200 km d'altitude les soviétiques vont
se livrer à toutes sortes d'expériences
scientifiques les liaisons avec la terre
sont bonnes les cosmonautes se livrent
actuellement à des expériences également
de contrôle médical bref le programme
prévu semble suivre après 24 jours dans
l'espace
c'est l'heure du retour sur terre pour
les trois cosmonautes le 30 juin 1971
mais tout ne se passe pas comme prévu
juste après la séparation de soyouz de
la station orbitale
une valse ouvre accidentellement dans la
capsule
la pression diminue et l'air vient à
manquer les trois soviétiques morts
asphyxiés en quelques secondes les
choses ont dû se passer très rapidement
parce comme il ya une pression
atmosphérique normale à l'intérieur de
la cabine le vide à l'extérieur la
moindre fuite provoque un appel d'air
extrêmement rapide et les hommes ont dû
en un temps très court
se retrouver complètement asphyxié
mourir par un but après ce drame
sa lutte un appui jamais accueilli de
cosmonaute le 16 octobre 1971 après 175
jours en orbite la station spatiale
soviétique s'est désintégré dans
l'atmosphère
[Musique]